now I've been lucky enough not to lose
anyone I love except my grandfather to
actual mortality but it doesn't mean
that I haven't experienced symbolic
death symbolic death in the form of love
lost you know there's a reason that
melancholic movies get under my skin and
why I can't look at most Instagram
photos for more than a few minutes at a
time because I get sad over something I
haven't necessarily lost yet you know
falling in love is like staring into the
Sun and finding that instead of blinding
you it illuminates you and all of a
sudden you went from being blind and
then you can see it's the moment of
feeling like you are complete for the
first time Roland Barthes says all of my
desires abolished by the planet another
satisfaction love is fulfillment love is
to overflow love is to spill over love
is aesthetic arrest love is the Italian
of experience love is getting caught up
in something larger than yourself
love is radiance beyond all previous
limits its consummation consecrations
and dance with the divine it's I went to
God just to see and I was looking at her
reflected right there in front of my
eyes that's love and so when you lose
love and break up with somebody who
cared about somebody in whose arms you
felt the promise of forever you felt the
promise of eternity you felt the promise
of souls merging and then to contemplate
the idea that there was a time when we
were together and now we are
how could it be so how could it exist
that once we were us and now we are not
and then you look at old videos and old
photographing you can't believe there is
a reality playing back there for you
you're seeing a replay of something that
was real or tangible and silent and
where to go and where to go